j'ai eu à prendre rapidement la fuite
elle est en sécurité à rejoindre ma
famille puis à peu près duré 15 minutes
après cela j'ai pensé à la croix rouge
était déjà bénévole à la croix-rouge
depuis plus d'un an dans l'équipe le cas
d'intervention je savais pas l'ampleur
mais j'avais vu le centre-ville en feu
danse était évident qu'ils auraient des
dizaines voire des centaines de
personnes qui auraient besoin et d'adp
qui auraient des plusieurs foot fric
donc avec mon cellulaire j'avais mis
numéro croix-rouge programme et donc
j'ai rejoint les autres bénévoles de
l'équipe locale est également là
la coordination montréal pour leur dire
qui arrivait quelque chose de gros et
qu'on aurait besoin du renfort de
l'équipe de partout au québec en fuite
si ce qui était arrivé cette nuit là
donc moi mes deux collègues l'ont été
les premiers à arriver à la polyvalente
le premier représentant de la croix
rouge sur place
on a déjà on avait déjà commencé à
réconforter les gens les accueillir et
dans le courant l'a dans les heures qui
ont suivi les équipes de sherbrooke de
saint-georges plus d'un peu partout au
québec sont venus nous est plus près de
100 bénévoles la croix rouge de toutes
les régions du québec qui sont nulles
dans cars 2 de l'opération d'urgence
c'est sûr que là ces événements là on
voulu verser ma vie de plusieurs façons
je dirais d'une part au point d'un point
de vue plus personnel du camp des
événements comme cela survienne en tout
cas pour moi saluent l'effet de me
ramener l'essentiel de donner goût de
vivre une vie qui était la plus conforme
possible à mes valeurs puis là dedans il
ya certainement de l'application puis de
la solidarité donc cela leur confère
davantage rend forcément mon goût de
m'impliquer avec la croix rouge
un mot qui nous qui nous décrit des
jauges pour ça a été un grand élan de
solidarité entre nous et en fait de
partout au québec
bon c'est tout le volet de la
reconstruction est en train de se faire
donc se refasse un milieu
reconstruite rempli de gens courageux je
pense et solidaire